is that your security guard behind you  the gun behind you  my son again  what is it  i won't ask you again then  [Music]  they'll hurt you when they have to  they or you  as a journalist if i'm trying to get  into these clubs and see how they  operate  i would say good luck  it's the military  they're covering their faces which is  never good  how often is it that you have cameras  never do you think there's a race war  coming i hope so  are you a nazi  [Music]  i've been doing it all my life i'll do  it till i'm late in the casket  it seems to me like there's a fire  spreading do you think it's too late to  stop this well everybody involved is  making money so it goes really deep  do you work with the cartel i'm actually  up there  do you trust these people they look at  you as prey  people want to kill you to ask your  questions  the black market will be here as long as  the legal market keeps screwing up  [Music]  you